nothing normal about j.j watt's tweet
from earlier today and i don't know if
he's trolling us if he's having fun if
he's sending messages subliminal
messages like when we used to get a
record kids you know what a record is
google and i'm sure they're out there
again though they've got the record
players you spin it backwards you get
hidden messages about who killed john
lennon or paul mccartney or whoever was
we know who killed john lennon it was
paul mccartney sorry i got my dead
beetles wrong but uh paul mccartney is
not dead or at least they say he's not
j.j watt mitochondria is the powerhouse
of the cell that was his seven word
tweet earlier today that has sparked all
sorts of speculation most of which
tongue-in-cheek i think
mitochondria is the same number of
letters as the buffalo bills so it means
he's going to buffalo the mitochondria
research center is located in buffalo jj
to the bills i've seen arguments like
there's a c in mitochondria it means
he's going to cleveland it's it's you
could make a case for almost any team
based upon that tweet
i don't know what he's trying to prove
and i think he's just kind of messing
with us and i kind of like it shireen
i love it mike he's trolling us isn't he
and you know he responded a couple days
ago to a cart it was obviously a
cardinals fan i think the twitter handle
was something like kylar to deandre or
something like that that tweeted to jj
watt and he actually answered it and
said you're gonna have to give me a
minute it takes me forever to order from
doordash it takes me like an hour to
order from doordash so you know as
you've said mike that teams want to know
what the cap is before they know how
much they're willing to pay j.j watt i
think that's where he is i think that's
why he doesn't have a team
because these teams are still waiting to
figure out what that final cap number is
going to be and how much they can commit
to jj watt maybe he doesn't get as much
as he thinks he's going to get mike or
maybe he gives some team a discount that
he really wants to go to if he wants to
win a super bowl there are plenty of
teams out there that are interested in
j.j watt and jj
watt will have his choice of of several
of those teams mike as we've heard the
titans are the only ones who've publicly
admitted that they have interest in jj
watt but we've heard all the other teams
out there who who reportedly have
interest in j.j watt and there's a
number of them that he can pick to go to
and he'll help him
i think the bottom line is no one is
going to sign j.j watt until they know
what the salary cap is and i think we
are a week at least away from knowing
the cap i'd like to think we'll know
what it is before march 10 when the
window closes on application of the
franchise tag because it's hard to know
what you're committing to if you don't
know what the cap is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports